[Applause]
[Music]
hello I'm Phil and welcome to today's
stadia connect in every stadia connect
we aim to share the latest news about
playing games on stadia and how the
platform is evolving and growing you can
see right away that there's something
different about this Kinect like many of
you I'm spending all of my time at home
and so are the rest of the stadia team
during this unique time when we are
feeling confined games enable us to
explore and connect in really meaningful
ways playing games at home we can step
outside through our imaginations into
fantastic worlds playing with friends
together online bridges the physical
barriers between us whether it's with
friends down the street across town or
around the world games can be a great
connector a few weeks ago we opened up
stadia to everyone in our 14 launch
countries to experience stadia for free
and included a number of free games
players can enjoy with stadium pro for
two months on us if you haven't yet
begun playing games free on stadia we
welcome you to join in today you can
play across a number of screens
including on devices you already own get
playing in a matter of seconds with a
gmail account and a connection to the
internet today you can begin playing
games on stadia two ways the first we're
giving everyone new to stadia two months
of free games through stadia Pro and
we've already extended free stadia pro
for existing members for two months as
well you can start playing all of those
games right away across your compatible
devices without waiting for installs
downloads or updates and remember you
don't have to buy anything to start
playing these games the second option is
to simply buy the games you want
directly from the stadia store your
access to those games will never expire
so you'll always be able to play them
when stadia is free you just pay for the
games so that's two ways you can choose
to build your gaming collection with
stadia one claiming free games through
stadia Pro and two purchasing individual
games through
our store over the last few months we've
been constantly adding new games to
stadia and I'm really happy to announce
that we are bringing five games from
Electronic Arts to stadia as part of our
partnership it all starts with Star Wars
Jedi fallen order coming this fall
followed by Madden NFL and FIFA we're
excited to bring these hugely popular
franchises to our players on stadia in
2020 and beyond and we'll have more news
to share about EA games on stadia later
this year now we're going to show you
just a few of the more than 100 new
games you can play in 2020 on stadia I'd
like to invite some of the stadia team
to tell you all about them over to you
Erin hi I'm Erin I have one of the
coolest jobs in the world working with
developers to build features that unlock
gaming experience is only possible on
stadia today we're shining a spotlight
on great games from devs big and small
that you'll be able to play on stadia
we'll start with one of the most
energetic and critically acclaimed
shooters of the year the incredible doom
eternal from the team at its software
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Slayers time is now
[Music]
if you haven't started playing doom
eternal yet you're missing out it's
ready to buy and play right now on
stadia now here's the world of beauty
and intrigue arriving today for purchase
on the stadia store
of knowledge
[Music]
if we speak with
[Music]
now let's see a game coming soon to the
stadia store creation and destruction
collide in Rock of Ages 3
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk for a second about our free
games with stadium pro steam world heist
the Turing test and zombie army for dead
war are all available to claim with
stadium pro for free starting in May
additionally a new campaign mission
add-on for zombie army four will be
available to buy on the stadia store
soon let's find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm especially happy to share this one a
first on stadia game about making games
and then playing them with your friends
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's take a look at wave break coming
first on stadia
[Music]
I'm going to hand the next part of the
presentation off to my friend Catherine
another member of the stadia team hi I'm
Catherine I'm lucky to be one of the
hundreds of people working every day on
making stadia a great place for gamers
many of you have reached out to share
your stadia stories take a look the
thing that surprises me the most have
Google stadia no download having the
ability to instantly launch the game no
update the lack of load time no installs
instant it's fast none of that exists on
stadia you just click at play click play
I'm off I can load up games and be into
them within no time whatsoever I really
love the ease of that as a Mon as a
business owner it's really hard to find
time to just sit down and play a game
but what's cool about stadia is it lets
me just start exactly from where it was
before having a disability cerebral
palsy I love the idea that I could play
stadia has really changed my way of
playing video games I can just open up a
Chrome browser once a game and I just
start playing right away I can access my
stuff from anywhere wherever I am no
matter what device I want I can play on
tablet it's hard for me to imagine
playing games any other way this is my
employment this is a match
[Applause]
[Music]
Longy Cydia was exciting but it was also
just the beginning of our work in fact
since November we've rolled out constant
upgrades to Cydia all without you having
to wait for a single system update now
the state could look at a few games were
teamwork counts most it's time for you
and your friends to become firefighters
in ember residents are trapped in a
burning building on 124th Street we
caught up with an ember responder about
to head inside oh yeah I'm gonna be
saving John so I really better be going
[Music]
John
[Music]
great news for John two more phrase
responders have come to help
[Music]
there's just no reason to use
traditional services when you've got
Ember
[Music]
this system John is about to rate his
exceptional amber experience one star
are you chewing amber the emergency
services revolution and become a
responder this may let's take a peek at
another first on stadia game where
players work together to get moving
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm andrée over the last few months I've
talked with many of you online listening
to your feedback and answering some of
your questions you've already seen a lot
of great games during the state of
Connect we've got a final announcement
we've been looking forward to sharing
new ways that stadia can make
world-class games available to more
people today we're thrilled to bring you
a fantastic hit game you can play right
away on stadia without waiting for a
download and without needing to pay for
anything massive game that you and your
friends can enjoy together for free
right now on devices your radio
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can play pop G for free on Stadium
right now no downloads and stalls or
patchen's required there is a click to
play link in the description of this
video when you click it you can quickly
join stadium pro for free
you'll get pop G in more games and you
can start playing instantly since pop G
on stadium supports cross play you'll
also be able to team up with your
friends playing pop G on consoles thanks
for joining us we hope that what we've
shown today can help you add more fun to
your lives right now we'll be back in
another state a connect the summer with
more news to share
[Music]
join us then when we'll be showing more
games headed to stadium until then for
the most up-to-date news follow us on
Twitter and it's our community blog
thanks for being here with us today see
you on Stadium
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]